these are the 61 seen changes in the
screenplay for the movie 1917 almost
every single one is labeled continuous
that's because this movie is 2 hours of
what appears to be one long
uninterrupted shot one shot films like
this are a stunning accomplishment of
coordination and timing and when done
right they make a movie feel like it's
unfolding in real time but of course
1917 isn't really one shot the movie
jumps between scenes shot all over the
United Kingdom they're stitched together
to look continuous a lot of that editing
wizardry happens thanks to some
extensive CGI but it also relies on some
basic tricks that have been around for
over 70 years and it all starts right
here with a suit jacket
when critics reviewed alfred hitchcock's
1948 movie rope they described it as a
movie that introduces a new method of
filmmaking in which all cuts dissolve
fade outs and other breaks in filming
continuity have been eliminated
that shooting plane is clear from the
very first page of the script the action
of the story is continuous that's
because a rope is based on a play having
no visible edits would make the movie
feel like it was playing out in real
time just like the play does but there
was one problem the cameras at the time
could only hold a thousand feet of 35
millimeter film or about ten minutes of
recording which meant that the
filmmakers couldn't just let the camera
run they had to find a way to hide cuts
when they changed film roles this is
what they came up with the camera
dollies in on a dark surface like this
jacket and one color obscures the entire
frame then the camera cuts a new shot
begins and the camera dollies back out
creating the illusion of continuity rope
contains ten edits over the course of 80
minutes those transitions alternate
between hard cuts and hidden cuts with
matching colors transitions like this
might look really obvious today but it's
basically the same trick used here in
Creede here in Birdman here in children
of men and here in Snake Eyes but if a
camera is moving sideways that color
block doesn't even have to take over the
whole frame that district number two by
putting together two similarly time
shots where an object passes in the
foreground editors can stitch two shots
together like in this long take from
children of men which is actually made
of six different shots where a dark car
frame helps transition from one shot to
another but if you speed up the camera
movement a little bit you get a
different kind of hidden cut in a whip
pan the camera moves so fast the image
becomes blurry by cutting from one shot
to another right as the movement is at
its fastest point you can make two shots
look like one that's how this scene from
1998 Snake Eyes moves from one shot to
another in what looks like a seamless
take so what does it look like when you
put all of these tricks
gather well the shop from Spectre the
2015 James Bond movie starts out in a
busy square in Mexico City they uses CGI
and motion blur to transition to a shot
filmed in a hotel a few blocks away then
a color match from this black jacket to
transition to a studio set near London
and a foreground object to take us back
on location in Mexico City but if the
stunts get more complicated in a long
take you might have to do more than hide
a cut you might have to hide an actor
that's where the final trick comes in
the Texas switch that's when a performer
and their double subtly swap places
which allows them to do stunts without
cutting it's how Captain America runs so
fast and how Dorothy changes colors all
without the camera cutting filming
digitally and using CGI it means that we
actually can capture entire movies in
one true take with none of these classic
tricks and there have been some stunning
examples of just that but the
limitations of early film gave us the
techniques to tell even more ambitious
stories by hiding cuts and you can
probably still see where they're hidden
if you know where to look
[Music]